benim en iyi bildiğim hikaye anlatacağım
size ekliyoruz hikayenin içerisinden
bazı evreleri sizlerle paylaşacağım
milattan önce 90'lı yıllar çok severek
yazdığım bilerek yazdım severek okuduğum
bölümden mezun oldum genç bir çevre
mühendisiyim fakat özel sektörde çalışma
şansım yok çünkü çevre mühendisleri
işlerini başka mühendisi arkadaşlar
yapıyor Dolayısıyla ne iş yapabilirim
diye başladım arayışta İzmir'de bir gıda
firmasının iş başvuru formunu doldurdum
ve orada amaç bölümüne dedim ki hayatıma
yön verecek bir başlangıç istiyorum
Pazarlama
37 bu çok sevdim öğretilenler hiç
bilmediğim bir meslekte yeni şeyler
öğreniyorum ve öğretilenler genellikle
de şuydu büyük balık ol yetmez hızlı
balık ol kaybeden olma kazanan ol
bunlarla eğitildiği miz biraz ben
kavramının güçlendiği Lider ol Yönet Sen
yaparsın halledersin bu takımı
yönetirsin diye diye pazarlama
kariyerimin üst noktalarına kadar çıktım
ilk çalışma hayatının kurumsal çalışma
hayatının hedefi Çok üst düzey bir iş
kadını olmak belki şirketler yönetmek
şirketlerin seosu olmak başkanı olmak
falandı fakat
Evet Ee o günlerde
yok artık Sığacık ismini biliyorsunuz
sıcağı taşınmış tık sıcacık O zaman iki
Bakkal bir Eczanesi olan hiç kimsenin
bilmediği bu ufacık bir köyde birkaç bin
nüfuslu sığacıkta yaşarken Biz yan
komşularımızla yerleşik köylüler de ben
altında araba şirket arabası her gün
şirkete arabayla gidiyorum geliyorum
hafta sonları arabamı atlıyorum
alışveriş merkezine gidiyorum elimde
Kağıt torbalarda geliyorum Bana göre çok
özenmesi çok havalı bir hayat yaşıyorum
veya komşumuz Çiftçi ki oranın yerlisi
köylüsü gelin kız hep bana özeniyor diye
düşünüyordum çünkü sabah erken
kalkıyorlar karı koca tarlalarına
gidiyorlar bütün gün tarlada lar hafta
sonu pazara çıkıyorlar Siz gah ları var
ürün satıyorlar iki çocukları var başka
bir hayattır yok Akşam gelince
yorgunluktan ölüyorlar hayal
var ya bu kız benim hayatıma nasıl
özleniyor dur altında araba sürekli
karton çantalar alışveriş yapıyorum
oraya gidiyorum oraya gidiyorum bugün
köye gittik yemyeşil bir ağacın altında
oturuyoruz sohbet ediyoruz annesi babası
şu çocukları kalabalık bir aile hep
beraber Ay ne güzel dedim bu ağaç bu
beybi nerede böyle yeşil yeşil soğan O
Gelin kızın suratındaki küçümseme benim
aslında hayatımda çok önemli kararlar
verememe neden olan bir Bakışlı mı öyle
baktı ki bana ve sen dedi Bu yaşına
kadar taze ceviz hiç görmedin mi bunu
burada ile söylediği zaman ben hep onu
özelliğini düşündüğüm bu küçük köylü
kızının aslında ne kadar daha zengin ve
ne kadar daha önemli olduğunu
bu önemli bir hayat yaşadığını fark
etmeye başladım henüz ve ondan aşağı
yukarı da bir yıl sonra kariyerimin çok
güzel İzmir'de bir kadın için çok güzel
bir noktasındayken istifa ediverdim bir
prensip kararıyla istifadan önce omzumda
pırpırlar işıltılı Güzel bir akvaryum
balığı iken den istifa ettikten sonra
yaklaşık 15 yıllık kurumsal Hayat
sonrası Cemal tertemiz bir okyanusta
küçücük İsimsiz bir balıktım bir tatil
için bile yoktu Sadece ismim vardı ama
Özgür düm de bağımsızlığım Bunun değeri
hiçbir şeyde ölçülemiyor çok sonra
İstanbul'a gittik İstanbul'da tekrar
kurumsal Hayat içerisine girmek
istemedim kolunda bir altın bilezik
İyi o zaman dedim ben bunu kurumsal
Hayat içerisine girerek yapmak zorunda
değilim şimdi biraz çalışayım freelance
pazarlama yol arkadaşlığı diye kendime
bir iş kurdum öyle güzel önemli büyük
firmalarla da çalışmaya başladım Daha
çok çalışıyordum daha çok yoruluyorum
ama hepsi mesafem vardı Ve gerçekten
özgürüm ve bağımsızım hayatıma
hobilerimi soktum fotoğraf çekmeye
başladım yazı yazmaya başladım seyahat
etmeye başladım fotoğraflarım DVD lerde
birikmeye başladıkça bir gün dedim ki
bunlar çeyiz sandığında 12 gibi bir iki
var Ne iş yapayım bunlarla sosyal
sorumluluk adına sergi açtım Yani benim
köşede DVD lerde bekleyen o resimlerim
gezdiğim Anılarım hep içimizde bir
yerlerde bekleyen ve insanlarla
paylaşmaya çekildiğimiz o hobilerimizi
ki güzel sergiyle çok güzel sosyal
sorumluluk gelir oldular
bu kitaplar yazdım öncesinde küçücük
sadece eşime dostuma hediye etmek için
kendi paramla bastırdığım küçücük bir
kitap yazdım onunla imza günleri bile
yaptım arkasından matbaa bir kitap
Yayınevi tarafından da basıldı o insana
günlerinin bir tanesinde bir kadın şöyle
geçerken ne var dedi Bunu ben de yazarım
ama sonra bir ortaokul öğrencisi geldi
abla dedi Ben kitap okumayı sevmiyorum
ve kendime de bugüne kadar hiç kitabı
almadım ama dedi Senin bu gecenin çok
rahat okunacak gibi görünüyor alacağım
ben bunu okuyacağım dedi hiç
giremezsiniz attığımız bir adamın karşı
taraftan nasıl alındığını ve Aslında
attığımız adımın karşıda nasıl
büyüdüğünü hiçbir zaman bilemezsiniz O
yüzden ilham alırken ilham vermeyi de
her
da beraberinde düşünmemiz lazım oğlum
benim cebimde her zaman Medeni cesaret
Oldu oldu Ve her zaman bir şey öğretmek
istedim Çünkü kurumsal hayatta
çalışırken ve özellikle pazarlama
kariyeri yaparken ne yaparsanız yapın
günün sonunda yaptığınız işler bir
klasörle çalıştığınız firmanın dolabına
kalkar Siz evinize bir şey
götüremezsiniz Ben hep istedim ki elimde
somut benim üreteceğim benim ürettiğim
bana dair bir şey olsun O yüzden ben
fotoğraf çektim O yüzden yazı yazdım o
yüzden kitap yazdım kendime ait bir
ürünüm olsun arzusuyla ve kaygısıyla
bunları yaptım Sonra Seferihisar'da Biz
bir arazi aldık Daha doğrusu alınırken
ben hiç ilgilenmedim eşim ilgilendi O
zaman hiç bu taraflarda biz
Ama ben yine freedos çalışıyordum
hobilerin ile ilgileniyordum ve arazimi
bana ne alalım Tamam yatırımı olacak
olsun falan derken alındı tapular
geçtiğin çekilen medim Ve arkasından
eşimle birlikte arazi görmeye gittik
zeytinler vardı yaklaşık 350 tane zeytin
evladımız var Evet o zeytin ağaçlarını
gördüğümüz al o kadar okudum ve daha
doğrusu çalıştım pazarlamadan öğrendiğim
iş hayatından öğrendiğim her şeyi bir
kenara atıp fizibilite yapmadan kar
zarar tablosu Bilmem ve çıkarmadan böyle
bir yatırım yaparsak kaç yılda amorti
eder falan hiç birisine bakmadan biz
dedik ki Biz burayı üreten bir yere
çevirelim
bu çevirelim 2014'ün sonunda aldığımız
arazisi 2015'te Biz orada üretmeye
başladık bir fiil geçen sene that
azalarında yol yapımı için sökülmüş Bir
ağaçtan haberimiz oldu idare 1250
yaşında yol yapımı için sökülmüş Tüh biz
onu sahiplendik toprağımıza koyduk geçen
sene 13 kasım2018 tutar mı tutmaz mı
tutar mı tutmaz mı 1250 yıl yaşamış bir
canlı sizin toprağımıza geliyor tutar mı
tutmaz bakarken bu sene Baharda güzeldi
her tarafından Filiz fışkı tıbbi şunu
anlıyorsunuz toprakla uğraşırken çok
sabır istiyor Çok Sadakat istiyor insan
egosuyla yönetirim karar veririm
Hallederim ben yaparım kazan
en büyük balık ol hızlı bolkol toprakla
uğraşırken bunların hiçbirisi işe
yaramıyor ancak bütünün bir parçası
olduğunuzda işler yolunda gidiyor çünkü
o kadar büyük bir döngü ki siz yönetin
ise yön etmeseniz de mevsimler o döngü
içerisinde hareket ediyor Siz karar
verseniz ne vermeseniz ve ağaç çiçek
açıyor meyvesini veriyor Sonbaharda
yaprağını döküyor Siz sadece başarılı
olmak istiyorsanız ben kavramından
sıyrılıp sadece o 360° bütünün bir
parçası olduğunuzu kabul etmeniz
gerekiyor beee da bizim için Çin yeni
den Doğuş'un yaşam enerjisinin değişim
döngüsünün aslında bir sembolü oldu
bu yılın ev an İstanbul'da hedex
konuşmalarının ilklerinden birinde
sabahtan akşama kadar 17 dakika süren o
değerli konuşmacıları dinlemiştim her
birisini ve sabahtan akşama kadar hiç
sıkılmadan dinlemiştim Ya bu nasıl bir
organizasyon herkese 17 dakika konuşuyor
ve güzel bilgiler ediyorsun Hiç
sıkılmadan saatlerce sizin şu an
yaptığımız gibi orada oturuyorsun 19 10
yıl önceydi o zaman demiştik ya bir gün
İleride acaba Ben de bir kere x konuşur
muyum ya olur mu Ama Ne anlatacağım Hadi
O Zaman Ki şeyle insan iyi gerçekten
kendi hikayesini anlatıyor kısmet bana
bugün t-rex İzmir bunun da konuşmaya
nasip etti değil Biraz da kendi
adımlarınız geçiriyor belki aranızda bu
hayali kuranlar var gel
o yıllarda ben rahat koltukta otururken
sizi bu kırmızı noktanın içerisinde
izlemek isterim İnşallah bu ve gerçekten
çok değişimi başlat başlıklı bir konuşma
biat formunda olmak çok heyecan verici
fakat 50 yıllık ömrümde bütün o
evrelerden geçtikten sonra gi hala devam
ediyorum anladım ki değişimi başlat diye
bir şey yok çünkü bu değişim çok büyük
bir döngü bir su tanesinin hareketi gibi
nehirden okyanusa okyanustan havaya
oradan kuyuya tekrar dereye toprağa çok
büyük bir döngü değişimi başlat diye bir
şey ben artık şu an kabul etmiyorum
Fakat şu varsa
bu harekete geçmeye Hazır Mısın Değil
Misin Medeni cesaretini kullanmaya Hazır
mısın değil misin o kocaman değişim
döngüsünün içerisine balıklama atlamaya
Hazır Mısın Değil Misin bütün hikaye bu
ve şu an size soruyorum değişim
döngüsünün içerisine patlamaya hazır
mısın değil misin Hazır mısın değil
misin Teşekkür ederim Hoşçakalın o
abone ol